[Music]
afghan math
2 300
equals the price of a kidney so how long
that will feed a family is unclear
i couldn't go out and beg for money i
was not able to beg then i decided to go
to the hospital and sell my kidney so i
could at least feed my children for some
time
welcome to modern afghanistan where the
organ trade is flourishing amidst a dire
economic crisis
99 of the donors selling kidneys are the
people encountering economic problems
and only one percent of donors are the
ones who donate their kidney to a family
member if needed
most donors come from poor families
and may not be aware of the consequences
plus the debts won't go away by
themselves
most of people leave the country fearing
for their lives but some also leave in
search of jobs and when those people
cannot make it to other countries they
come back home and they have to pay the
money they had borrowed for their travel
costs and to do that they sell their
household belongings or sell their
kidneys some people even decide to sell
their children
the chaotic u.s nato withdrawal and the
taliban takeover pushed afghanistan into
financial chaos
subsequently aggravated when the west
froze afghan assets abroad and when
foreign funding was suspended
the un is now launching a 5 billion aid
appeal
this is a stop gap an absolutely
essential stop gap
measure that we are putting in front of
the international community today
without this being funded there won't be
a future we need this to be done
otherwise they will there will be
outflow they will be suffering
for those who have sold their organs
the suffering has already long been
there
you